l'ancien hôtel de ville de saint denis
durant les années 1850 1860 la colonie
connaissant une période prospère
plusieurs municipalités font construire
de nouvelle mairie dessiné par
l'ingénieur pierre émile grenard celle
de saint denis est livrée en 1860 près
de quinze ans après la pose de la
première pierre
s'étendant sur plus de 1300 m² ce vaste
bâtiment carré de 37 mètres de côté
reste à ce jour l'hôtel de ville le plus
imposant de lille
offerte aux regards des passants les
façades donnant sur les rues de paris de
la compagnie ont vu l'objet d'un
traitement plus raffinée que celle
située à l'arrière du bâtiment leur
style néoclassique correspond au mode
alors en vigueur en france
métropolitaine
culminant à 24 mètres de haut un beffroi
domine entre officiel inspiré de
l'architecturé italienne une galerie à
deux niveaux entoure la cour intérieure
au centre de laquelle se trouve une
majestueuse fontanes en font
un escalier à deux volets conduite au
premier étage où se situe trois grandes
pièces de réception
lieu de toutes les grandes
manifestations de la vie communale
jusqu'à l'inauguration du nouvel hôtel
de ville en 1979 le grand salon
accueille aujourd'hui des conférences
un mobilier ancien et des tableaux de
maurice menardo récemment restaurée
décor la salle des mariages
monument historique depuis 1975 l'ancien
hôtel de ville de saint-denis a fait
l'objet de plusieurs campagnes de
rénovation entre 1987 et 2001